what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a kevin samuels clip
modern women value freedom or family
before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos i
actually moved to england in two days
and it's been incredibly stressful so
drop a subscribe
like comment whatever you can do would
be so helpful to just help the channel
grow and support me when i moved to
england
how are you
i'm fine how is it going i'm enjoying
the show
so what are we going to talk about the
two thirds we're going to talk about the
dating costs what is it
all right so
you're unmarried
no i'm not that yes
any children
no children
okay so what do you want as far as
outcome of what's the outcome you want
of the relationship
the outcome will be to build um to build
this dynasty well david for survival
that's what you had said i like that
that
they didn't work survival
do you want to be married
i
i don't
i don't
okay
um
then
why
it's it's been a
it's a definition of it that gets me not
willing not wanting to i've been engaged
twice already the last one he passed
away
unfortunately he committed suicide so
with that it's just like i got close
twice and now what's the definition of
being married
well well i only know the church version
which is my grandmother and my mother
which they both were married my grandma
was married like three times so
there's no definition but she tells me
now that the definition is to be a wife
and
have kids that's the only thing is
really to have kids she wants me to have
kids but what i'm asking if you want to
be married you say no you said no it's
because the definition and you haven't
told me what's wrong with it
church religion the religion way
is the rich religion
we grew up pentecostal so it was more
pentecostal christian i guess oh my gosh
this is random but one time i like was
lost and i was trying to find my church
but i wandered into this pentecostal
church and oh my gosh i've never seen
this lady was just like yelling and
she's like the most enthusiastic sermon
i have ever seen in my life i only saw
like 10 seconds but
let me tell you
every continent on this planet practices
marriage
right then different religious practice
marriage
yes
so that can't be the overarching reason
i don't know any successful ones really
that's probably not right that's that's
operating out of fear kevin samuels
talks about that a lot like you can't
be afraid of things just because they
might not work out
you know that's cause of y'all
because of women oh she's mad you know
what the number will cause for divorce
is
women filing the papers uh cheating or
finances cheating or finances
oh that's right
men don't believe men don't leave in
general y'all do
but the first thing you said you wanted
to do was build
yes
okay then how do you build anything
without a
foundation well that's what the man will
bring to the table i would believe
uh you for me you got tupac on your
shirt right yes you can grab a dmx
i have i'm not really actually no not
really you know who you've heard of him
now
yes i have heard of him dmx was with his
uh
spiritual partner building for 13 plus
years and then when he died suddenly
she got nothing
all the building
see
far too often in the black community we
always talk about this build [ __ ] and
it's just a house of cards
because we don't do stuff the right way
and when i asked you about marriage all
i've heard is about what your grandmama
and
possibly said was negative and at 35
you can't tell me nothing about it
except i don't like it but you can't
tell me not to think about it
i stand correct
i'm just saying i mean it's an exchange
of ideas you can't tell me nothing about
it
so man so a marriage means little to
nothing
why did the lgbt community fight so hard
to get recognized because they had civil
unions
they had all the things common law
married people could have they just had
a few things that they couldn't have why
they fight so hard to get it if it
didn't matter
it matters it it you're right that is a
that's a good
that's a good analogy i like it um
that's a good get my brain working
is it because of the way that united
states
pretty much
idolize it as being you know needed
i think you should find out before you
say you don't want it
you live in the united states
i mean you live here so
you say you don't want to do it because
of what you don't even know what you're
talking about what you're saying is
against
that's that's right so my ques my
question is that do you care if you
marry a black do you care if you're with
a black man white man hispanic do you
care
um
no
all right i've dated
but what man would you want to deal with
a black man
then why uh you know why we can't build
nothing
because i will because there are women
in outright open rebellion against any
structure
this call has been good a good just a
good understanding of why we can't build
anything
because when men are calling for order
structure and discipline our women are
calling for free spirit and chaos
based in nothing other than
ignorance and feelings
we can look at every other group and
they build from a how do you build a
country
you build a country from a community how
do you build a community a community is
a group of what
individuals but it's also more it's a
group of what
and
men and and the fundamental unit of a
community is what
no the fundamental unit of a community
is a family oh right oh goodness oh
goodness i
you can tell this lady has not thought
this through like at all
you got a bunch of individuals
so how do you build by yourself
what's the hot what's the largest
structure you can do it alone
so i'll go back again why don't you want
to be married
and i want you guys to understand that
if we have our women in open rebellion
to structure
discipline and foundation how do we
build anything
because this is a free country
can nobody make you do nothing that you
don't want to so if a black man wants to
build
and the building blocks start with he
wants to build a build a nation build a
community
build a neighborhood
build a family
he needs to skip over you and go to the
white woman because she understands how
to do that
because she was raised learning the
value of it
right he needs to skip over you
well you don't want it
they do white women hispanic women
middle eastern women asian women they
all want this
they they they're all they're okay with
the foundation the structure and the
need so they need to skip over you
why not why should they why should they
go here and teach you why should i why
should they skip over you and get to the
women who are already ready to do the
job ready for work for duty sir watch it
because
because of the outcome of the the
foundation of it is i mean as far as the
kids
and whatnot
they should they should pick they should
pick you based upon what
race
no no no no just the just the structure
of the the kids from a black and black
no no no there is no structure i mean
what structure does a woman who wants to
know doesn't want marriage okay
you can't you're under no discipline
no structure no foundation so that means
having a child with you would be making
a chaotic child
so what i'm saying is a black man who
wants some structure
foundation this one a family a community
a nation
needs to skip over women who don't want
those things
so why should he not why she go to why
should he not go to the non-black women
who already know these things and want
them and are ready for the job to get
with women who share your reflection who
don't want it
because i well now that you put it that
way me thinking about it just a little
bit um the the other race
don't
it's like it's it's still learning for
them as well for culturally wise the
culture difference so it'd be for me to
be the same difference in helping no
it's not no it's not no it's not no no
teaching you how to be under discipline
is not teaching another woman how to be
in the culture white women can make
macaroni and cheese and collagen
yeah that's what you see this is why
this is a good conversation because
black women you become such
independent
that you're no real good to a man who
wants to build anything and the ultimate
sales pitch to black men is marry us in
our free
range wild state
because we are black
and then break us
and train us ain't my job to break you
and train you i want to get somebody
who's already ready to go and i'll teach
you how to season the mashed potatoes in
the greens
lowry's onion salt garlic salt salt
pepper
ain't hard to teach them how to do it
white girls already
going to dr miami getting bbl's doing it
better than y'all
they're running over here waiting for
the men and y'all sitting back so if you
don't keep what else who do you get with
okay you're gonna go over to the white
guy hispanic guy my legion asia they
ain't accepting free range
while women they're not they're not
they're not expecting wild unbroken
women they don't do that
do that
do you know any group of men who accept
i actually found out the other day that
i cannot cook mac and cheese
i can't i don't have it in me i tried i
don't really like mac and cheese like
that but i tried to follow a recipe the
other day and cook it for my boyfriend
and it did not go well like at all he
like threw it away it was pretty sad
free range wow
not a not a group but as far as no not
we don't we're not worried about
individuals now we're talking about the
group so you can't build it you can't
build
so this all started back to
we can't have nothing because y'all
y'all want to be
free
you're free that's cool
you're free to buy a dog and die alone
oh gosh but what you can't do
is when a black man
goes past you and gets with a latina
because he wants to build a family you
got to say good job brother you got to
smile at that man and say i'm glad to
see you happy brother
no no no you gotta and you gotta
legitimately mean it yes
yeah we don't see that this day yeah
when a black man when a black man gets
with somebody who's not black black
woman the first one to throw stones
because he should be with a black woman
which i don't want to say my mom she
married after me she was
back to an italian so
i don't see that
at all and then after that he was
watermelon you know so you know another
one so it's just
okay we don't i don't see that i
congratulate whoever makes you happy
good okay okay so how so if you never
get with anybody never get married what
do you do for a living
for me oh i am an entrepreneur so i have
my own businesses
one is real estate investment and the
other one is
yes
and um
and the other one i my other hobby is
body work so i do body sculpting and
yeah okay let's get to the end between
ages 65 and 85 when you cannot work
another day in your life nobody will
hire you you cannot work you cannot work
you cannot work no other job you cannot
work and you live between 65 and 85 are
you going to have your 2.4 million
dollars to retire on cash
age 65
nope 65
no time now
i've i've been doing a lot of no no no
that's that's a yes no that's a yes or
no
ma'am no okay no as of now so what are
you going to do so if you don't have a
husband
and you don't have a family
who's going to take care of you
oh gosh
why are you asking the tough questions
when your money runs out and you can no
longer work
you mean a man
no i'm asking you yeah
no no no no no no no no
no no you're not getting married no
children 65 years old
when you run out of money
who's going to take care of your age
itself
when your money's gone and you can't
work another day
who's gonna take care of you
hopefully one of my siblings but no i no
one no one
so what does that mean so no one's going
to take care of you what does that mean
where are you going to be
um let me finish my five leg language
book
no no she did not
she's in the corner
she has no answer we're going down your
path i have my idea but we're going down
your path you're a real estate body
sculptor fine where you gonna be at 65
with no husband no foundation no nothing
no keys where you gonna be when your
money runs out
nobody's taking care of you what does
that mean where does that end
um by myself where
in a home by myself no no no homes
require
money
homes require money you have no money
i don't know where i'll be homeless
say it again homeless say it again like
say it like it's real
no
uh man man where do you where do men who
run out of money
and have no family
end up
what do they end up
thank you same place you go end up
homeless see this whole family and
husband and kid think it's not a game
it's not an option
unless you're making enough money to
have enough room to retire on and live
the rest of your life talking about you
will be in a hurdle they don't give free
utilities they don't give free food
medical end-of-life care is far more
expensive elderly women cost the most on
the planet and this is what i ultimately
do this show for to crystallize the
young black women to realize y'all are
playing and life ain't playing with you
you got the street to look forward to
we won't have social security
we won't have social security there are
no there are no government shelters for
agent women the west is not set up for
elderly singles and if you want to catch
a clue go look on what's going on in
california right now tent cities are
popping up and you know who's populating
most of these women
and you know something and nothing more
than nothing more vulnerable than the
elderly homeless
woman
you can't keep nothing if you have this
and you on the street and i want it how
you going to keep it
if you have this and i want it or
somebody want it how you going to keep
it you're going to call the police how
you going to do that pigeons ain't got
no cell phone
what you going to do everything you
everything you have
somebody else bigger stronger quantity
you're too weak to stand out there by
yourself this ain't a game ladies
but every other group of women seems to
have this clue and our women seem to
think that you can just go through life
being no disrespect real estate and body
sculptors and entrepreneurs
and 74
of black women make 50 000 or less
oh my gosh isn't that high
oh my gosh that's like nothing i made
that right out of college
like literally right out of college
instead of black women make more than
seventy five thousand dollars
are you in the nine percent
yes are you okay i'm in my presence
right now as well so i i see it in los
angeles if you and
seventy-five thousand dollars a slice of
pizza a coca-cola is fifteen dollars in
los angeles
but this is where all these artsy this
is what i mean y'all
and i'm pesquitarian so i eat everything
is fresh um i go to market every two
three days
things of that matter so yeah i
understand i i unders i i understand you
you don't unders i've totally been
taking in your information from since
may you know since i found you in may so
i totally understand how it's not a game
i've been dating intentionally
so
you know that part well i'm not even
dating actually i'm like i haven't been
dating but you know
um
you're 35 oh gosh
so you're about to cross into what i
call no man's land
when we were cut free from shadow
slavery there was no real plan to
integrate us into the country
we still managed to stay together in
large part due to segregation
but after segregation the civil rights
movement in the 60s when the great
society offered black women
government subsidy
your grandmothers
and mothers chose to take
poultry benefits over a black man
and until black women address that
original sin and come back to your men
because ain't no other group of men
coming to you
just like white women black women were
surprised when white women voted for
donald trump after the [ __ ] grabbing
scandal because every other group of
women know that you got a stick for your
man every other group of men realize
that if we got three kids we got to
invest the money in the boy not the girl
but in our community boys at the bottom
and our women due respect are running
around out here
in your marrying and breeding and
marrying and dating years
do it being an entrepreneur instead of
realizing i
i don't have high income skills
i need a man
so when i ask you do you want to get
married the structure
you like the structure of the concrete
better
what i need people to understand is
whatever your fear is
your greater fear should be
dying on the street
okay right
and that day will be a lucky day because
that the day the misery will be over
that'll be a good day
the day before you die is the last is
the last bad day
you know have you ever seen elderly
people on the street high blood pressure
diabetes
infection no medical insurance have you
have you ever been to skid row
no
take a run by skid row this looks good
around los angeles river go check out
what people are doing who are really
homeless this isn't a goddamn game
oh gosh no that's that is real life i
i know but at 35 you're talking about i
eat pescatarian and clean and so forth
and it's like okay cool
but you need a man and you need a family
that's how this world is set up right
it's not set up for individuals and our
community is at the bottom our dollar
doesn't even circulate eight hours
and like it or not
in this conversation many black women
are going to hear winter's coming
because unlike black women black men
have more time in our lives to get it
fixed you don't right
after 40
so i'm going to make a suggestion
i need you to really sit back and think
about what the fear is
because the fear that
that most of our women have comes from
older black women lying and teaching you
guys
wrong okay that's the one thing it's
like
i do believe the saying that like women
keep women single because i like
i don't know a lot of the time like
girls do not give other girls good
advice
okay guys
i'm so tired this is probably gonna be
my last video um until i moved to
england on tuesday which is like so
exciting um so don't forget to subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell i'll talk to you guys next time